Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
my Loki season 2 trailer video we finally
have some footage from d23 and there's a ton
of brand new footage in Easter eggs it's a big
trailer they confirm what's going on with some of
the new characters and what's going on with the
new version of the TVA this new timeline so I'll
explain that and what's going on with Kang Loki
Sylvie Mobius rensslayer pretty much everybody's
coming back from season one so we'll go through
all the footage it's really cool if you're brand
new to the channel I will be doing videos for
all the episodes just like season one be sure to
subscribe to get everything it'll be releasing in
the summer of next year 2023 probably around the
same time Loki season 1 Premiere that means June
beginning of the trailer footage it starts with
a ding of the elevator and the TVA like that main
elevator reaching the main floor in our main Loki
who came back to this new timeline version the TV
at the end of season one walks out all careful
like he has no idea what's going on he's really
scared very unsure and he sees someone from
the TVA reading from like a small manual in
the main room he says hello like he's unsure of
what's going on or who this person is but then
immediately glitches out and this happens several
times throughout the trailer where they make it
seem like at least for him specifically time is
broken and he glitches all over this new version
of TBA that probably has something to do with
the events of the Kang Multiverse War because
throughout the trailer he's trying to explain the
Kang Multiverse War to Mobius and what's going on
with Kang himself on all of Kang's variants like
the king Multiverse War itself is causing time
to change and break this creepy music box type
of soundtrack comes into the trailer and plays
across the entire trailer just to make you
feel as uneasy as possible like everything
has changed and he's trying to figure out what's
changed as he's going throughout the different
trailer scenes like what's different what's gone
wrong why does everybody seem so weird and even
though they cut the trailer footage out of order
the first place he glitches to in the trailer is
a brand new office on a new floor like there are
a bunch of new locations that they go to in the
TVA like you would expect them to do in season
two it's this massive location like this entire
bubble this little pocket Dimension so of course
they're going to explore it through future seasons
of the show but the office that he glitches to is
completely empty like there's nobody there it's
super weird things get a little bit more uneasy
they jump cut to the main control room like the
main room here that they showed several times
during season one there's no one there within
there's no one around him but all the computer
consoles around him are glitching out it's sort
of like something has happened and everyone
has temporarily disappeared I think that also
has something to do with the events of the king
Multiverse war changing the timeline so to speak
they jump cut to him on a desert landscape outside
and there's a different scene that they cut on top
of it a voiceover of him trying to explain
the events of season one and Kang to Mobius
and he says this is going to sound strange I've
been pulled through time and as he's saying that
there's another scene of him being pulled through
time literally glitching across a hallway like
he's break dancing through time and space his
voice over speech says I've seen terrible things
and they show him in a new room of the TBA and
it seems like there's some special power source
like it's a circular room that's all white and
there's something glowing at the center of it that
he's looking at he says he's seen awful things
continuing what now seems like a debrief session
with the new version of Mobius and one of these
interrogation rooms so that might be where the
entire voice over conversation early on is coming
from he's still wearing his TV8 outfit that he had
at the end of season one so this seems like it's
like right at the beginning of season one where
he finds Mobius and has to re-explain everything
like this is who I am you know me even though you
technically don't know me like this is the first
time that this version of Mobius has seen him
there's a scene of him in another new room with
someone from the TBA dressed in what looks like a
very King themed outfit like something similar to
what he who remains Kang was wearing at the end of
season one he also has some gold bands and purple
robes it seems like it's inspired by the Rama Tut
outfit like something from ancient Egypt and he
destroys a painting on the wall depicting the
timekeepers holding the sacred timeline in their
hands like it's a wall painting depicting the
Miss Minutes video that we saw at the beginning
of season one Loki uses one of the TVA weapons
to remove it revealing behind the wall is this
giant gold statue of Kang's face and it's kind
of like the one above rensslayer's desk in the
judge's offices during season one except that
was a wooden carving of the timekeepers faces but
this time it's of Kang's face like he's trying to
reveal the truth who is behind the timekeepers
it was Kang all along post all your Agatha memes
as they slowly zoom out on Kang's face you can
also see this blue head that seems like it's been
severed in the front here like it's meant to be a
parallel for season one when they cut the head off
of the timekeeper robots you also see Mobius over
on the left here so it seems like there's a bunch
of them in this room here and he's just trying to
explain to them the truth of the matter like this
is what's really going on with Kang they confirmed
the release date is next summer like I said it's
probably going to be around the same time that
Loki season 1 premiered at least it probably with
their planning which would make it in June they
reveal another room inside the TVA this one has
a lattice Dome revealing the sky in this little
pocket Dimension the TVA occupies outside the main
timeline like you see a lot of the space outside
the TVA through different buildings then they're
in another new room revealing the cake Juan from
everything everywhere all at once is playing a
brand new character they actually brought him on
stage during the d23 presentation like guess who
we got they said that he's playing a TV8 archivist
in the room they're in just seems like an archives
room where they store really dangerous or really
important items that they don't just outright
destroy or send to the trash planet and Loki makes
in everything everywhere all at once reference he
says this is about everything during this scene
while they cut this in the trailer then there's
another new scene of Sylvie in a record store
in the past maybe it's in the 70s or the 80s
when records were more prevalent and she's just
in This Record Store listening to records then
there's a new scene of Casey walking through the
back rooms of what seems like the TVA like this
little crowded room in the back of everything some
secret place then Loki tell Mobius there's nothing
to stand between this world and utter destruction
they show another new character I'm not sure who
this is supposed to be he's obviously referencing
the king Multiverse War and the changing timeline
they jump to the movie premiere episode in the
1970s I've already done a much bigger video
about this because the movie that's premiering
here is the zaniac movie which itself is a comic
book character so it's like a reference within a
reference within a reference so it's a very meta
episode because zaniac himself is sort of like
a parody on comic book characters inside the MCU
and at this particular movie theater there's
a bunch of those fake in Universe MCU movies
that themselves are references to other real-life
Marvel movies I'll post a link in the description
for my other longer video on that because there
are a lot of Easter eggs in different parts of
the scene that they didn't include in the trailer
like kingo's original movie is also playing at
this movie theater because this is in the 1970s
then Loki steps into a tank-like room through a
metal door they finally reveal the first footage
of rensslayer she's wearing white like she's
all surprised looking at something she has a
new haircut so I'm assuming this might be the
same version they jump back to the scene of Loki
revealing Kang's face and he tells mobius war is
coming obviously talking about the Kang Multiverse
War there's another new scene of Loki fighting a
couple different TV agents at the same time in
this domed room using his magic there's a bunch
of new scenes of Loki in that zaniac episode
in his tux during the 1970s running through
the streets trying to catch the zaniac character
then there's another scene of Loki inside a new
TVA room with consoles and screens everywhere
and he's glitching into it so like it's during
all the scenes of him glitching around the TVA
but he's falling through midair and is a big
joke similar to the Thor Ragnarok joke where he
falls out of midair like Doctor Strange's trap
I've been falling for 30 minutes only this time
he's been glitching for 30 minutes or whatever
through time and space across the TVA in a bunch
of this episode then they jump back to the zaniac
episode when they're at the movie premiere in
Mobius jokes that this is all just a little over
the top don't you think which they also use as a
joke about the entire Loki series like the trailer
itself like don't you think the premise of Loki
season 2 is a little ridiculous and over the top
and of course Loki replies to him like within
context I thought it was spot on like he thinks
that the zaniac movie is a good movie but it's
also a bit of a joke about Tom Hiddleston himself
saying the Loki series is the best series ever
of course Loki would say that his own series is
the best but the other joke is that during this
scene there are two Loki's here like this seems
like another variant of Loki or something weird
is going on then they have a super quick Montage
of a bunch of different scenes it starts with
Loki in his regular uniform explaining things
to Mobius again at the beginning of the Season
there's another scene of Loki in Mobius in his
regular uniform looking at someone behind a desk
there's another scene of Loki trying to pry open
the main TVA elevator doors because it's not
working right there's a scene of Mobius inside
a spacesuit not really sure what's happening in
this episode and this new scene is of a brand
new TVA judge like rensslayer like this seems
like whoever's leading this version of the TBA
You Can Tell She's Like the highest ranking
official there because she's got the special
Sash on rensslayer was the only person we saw
wearing the sash like that during season one
there's a scene of Mobius yelling at Loki
through that porthole in the middle door that
he just stepped through there's another scene
of Loki falling through mid-air outside the
TVA like he's jumped outside from one of the TVA
buildings then after they played the Loki season
2 title they had a little trailer post-credits
saying like this wouldn't be a Marvel trailer
if the trailer itself didn't have a post-credits
scene where he and Mobius are sitting at a desk
inside a new cafeteria room so it's similar to the
cafeteria scenes that they had in season one where
they're both talking to each other about some
big plan that they have they said this is way
cooler looking because the room that they're
in is like the circular Matrix looking room
like the architect's room had all the monitors
around them in this circular room except this
is a cafeteria they're sitting in so these are
all like lunch receptacles around there where
they can grab food and Loki's joking with Mobius
about how everybody in his life has told him he's
a terrible person like he's being hard on himself
emobius replies saying who said that you were like
who said that you were bad and Loki lists off
like all the Avengers characters he references
a bunch of scenes from the first Avengers
movie from the Marvel Phase 1 movies because
guys remember this version of Loki's story in
the regular MCU movies ended with the events of
the first Avengers movie he references the Iron
Man scene then he references the Captain America
scene he mentions the Black Widow scene of her
dressing him down verbally then he mentions the
Coulson scene like another big Coulson reference
in the MCU he references Thanos but remember the
Thanos scene that he is mentioning would have
had to have been when he first met Thanos not
the infinity war scene like there's this whole
storyline of Loki is that they skipped over when
he first went to Thanos and made the bargain with
him he mentions the Nick Fury scene where Nick
Fury was putting him in that prison he mentions
his father Odin yelling at him he mentions Thor
yelling at him those are all during the events of
the first Thor movie then he references the events
of Loki season 1 when he says Miss minutes yelled
at him then references the many times that Mobius
yelled at him in season one because remember
the timeline has changed so technically this
version of Mobius has no memories of what happened
during season one so like Loki has to re-explain
everything to him there'll be six episodes total
and obviously this will tie in with the movies and
lead up to what's happening in Avengers 5 Kang
Dynasty and then Avengers 6 Secret Wars but if
you spotted any other Easter eggs in the trailer
footage that I didn't talk about in the video or
any big questions about what's happening during
season two just write them Below in the comments
I will do more trailer videos as we get more
footage because there is still a lot of stuff that
they haven't revealed yet my Full House of the
Dragon episode 6 video will post tomorrow be sure
to enable alerts for my channel so you don't miss
that everyone click here for my other Loki season
2 first look video at that other brand new footage
and click here for my house of the Dragon episode
6 video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!